[Music]
the patriots will have to move forward
without tight end rob gronkowski we
talked earlier about the draft as a
possible place where the patrons could
find a replacement any names that jump
out to you that the patriots could say
hey hey this guy all of a sudden looks
more interesting to us well there's
there's a lot of tight ends that are in
the draft that are talented now i mean
one that is the most gronk like is the
big guy from iowa tj hawkinson that's
the one guy that you if you want to say
the parallels between being really good
in the past game and then also not just
being a pass game tight end being a run
blocking tight end as well uh hawkinson
can do both at a very high level just
like grant could but the patriots would
have to make moves to get that type of
player uh mike i mean that i i think
hawkins is a top 15 top 20 pick in the
nfl draft now there's other guys that
are down the lines that are athletes
noah fan uh he is a guy that certainly
the patriots could use another iowa
tight end irv smith from alabama i think
those are the three names you're going
to hear most commonly used throughout
the first round and irv smith's playing
at alabama hey of course can uh catch
the ball make plays with the ball of his
hands but came from alabama too where
you know they like to run the ball and
they expect the tight end to block too
so that could be somebody that's on the
patriots radar radar when all said and
done too and like i said earlier bill
belichick surely has a plan shirley
thought the flow chart through 50
different ways this happens we go this
way that happens we go that way they
will surely have something in mind and
at the end of the day they still have
tom brady they still have julian that's
right but they won that super bowl a
couple of years ago without gronk he was
injured we never thought they could win
a super bowl without him and they did
now they're gonna have to move forward
all season without him into the
postseason if they make it if they make
it and they're not as dependent on him
at this point of the patriots shelf life
as they were but he still was very good
i know he was
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports